so I'll start off by saying a little bit
about global assessments of biodiversity
then say some of the issues questions
and then I go through four case studies
so the first one was my Dookie
biodiversity action plan and we
mentioned that on Tuesday but we did a
volley transfer study there so what we
had was we split the study into eight
regions of the UK and we tried to value
or transfer values from one region to
another and see if that valuation
transfer worked the second study is a
study or review i did for Defra looking
at best practice for valuation in
developed countries or sorry in
developing countries so mostly study or
valuation techniques have been developed
for undertaken in Europe and North
America can we simply apply those in
developing countries the third one is a
study edit or is involved in in Solomon
Islands no it's a choice experiment
there and what we try to do in that
study was take some of the
recommendations we had in this def a
review and apply to the solomon island
case study and it's quite a neat study
so you should enjoy that and the fourth
one is currently people in scottish
agriculture College are doing an
upscaling exercise on teeb and we've got
some provisional results so I'll show
you them they're not published yet but
very red scooters to show you what
what's happening in terms of that so
global assessments the first kind of
famous one was Constanza which i think
you've all heard about and it team
interim report also use a global
assessment and both of those studies
were based on upscaling studies from
local valuation exercises and try not
scale it to the rest of the world so if
we're looking at value transfer not
scaling what does that mean so say we've
got a study here and see the west coast
of America and from that study tight
with to the evaluation and we've worked
a dollar
you for that study site so maybe a
forest somewhere in west coast America
then can we take that study and say okay
from that information from the study in
West Coast America can we see something
in Connecticut about it and you can
probably think well it's all America
you've got similar incomes the ecosystem
pipe is quite similar so there's a good
chance that you can transfer for values
from West East Coast America so you've
got good chance of doing it what about
if we try and transfer this American
study to Europe well then again we've
got similar incomes to America there
might be different culture ailments but
some of the and the ecosystems might be
quite similar so it chances are that
you're probably going to be reasonably
successful on that but maybe a big
question is can we take a study from
America and translate it Africa South
America particularly when incomes are
different the ecosystems might be
different and we're trying to infer
values of mecca system services from one
site to another and that may be
questionable so if we think about global
assessments for value transfer what are
some of the key challenges to it first
of all it does actually folly transfer
work and they can we test it in the
control setting so to answer that I'll
do my Dookie biodiversity action plan
where I'm trancing transferring values
across different regions of UK where
it's based on the same survey instrument
so we should be able to volley transfer
in that setting and we can't do in that
control setting then it does question
whether they can transfer across regions
using different studies